et en direct avec nous pour en parler
sur la télé france ce christian show via
le père de s cédric souvient bonsoir
merci et d'être avec nous sur rt france
alors cette enquête de l'igpn on vient
de le voir remet en cause les
témoignages des policiers le jour de
l'arrestation
est ce que c'est une surprise pour vous
enfin oui et non parce que depuis depuis
le début ont depuis le début on savait
qu'il y avait un tissu de mensonges
il y avait des témoins il y avait il y
avait des enregistrements et et tout
s'avérait contre les mensonges que que
comment les policiers d'aulnay il y
avait aussi la préfecture enfin tout le
monde tout le monde a menti du début
jusqu'à la fin du moment où j'ai appelé
à 10h30
et puis que ma belle fille a été au
commissariat on n'a pas pu avoir de
nouvelles avant 16 heures parce que il
est en train de préparer une version
tous ensemble avec le le commandent le
policier de la bac est venu qui était
pas sur les faits quand ça s'est passé
et qui a lui orchestré qui a orchestré
toute la la commande le manège ce qu'il
fallait raconter et après ils ont tous
suivi ses conseils et je pense que lui
fait partie du groupe étant donné que
c'est le conjoint de de la policière et
qui est pour moi aussi coupables que
parce qu'elle a fait qu'un tissu de
mensonges et réussie de casser le
téléphone de cédric pour effacer les
preuves qui pourraient y avoir dessus
donc pour moi les quatre les quatre
puces lui c'est tous des menteurs ils
ont tous essayé de camoufler 1 meur est
pour moi je depuis le début je dis que
ça meurt qu'on a tué mon fils et on l'a
tué à un moment donné je pense que si un
messie un homicide volontaire et non un
volontaire pour moi c'est un homicide
volontaire il a été jusqu'au bout
la preuve c'est qu'ils s'y est repris à
deux fois c'est bien écrit c'est bien
vue par l'igpn
je remercie les epn du travail qu'ils
ont fait et les juges surtout les juges
travaillent qui font eux qui est
colossal
donc aujourd'hui
u2 il ya plus de discussions trois
policiers ont été mis en examen pour
homicide involontaire est ce que vous
pensez que ces nouveaux éléments vont
pouvoir requalifier l'anc est en cours
on espère on espère vivement avec avec
toute la famille et puis les avocats on
espère que ça va être qualifié on espère
que monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui va reprendre les choses en
main et qui va tenir l'engagement
qu'avait tenus castaner le ministre
castres hier à l'époque
donc c'est le ministère on va dire si
l'homme n'est plus là il ya au moins le
ministère qui avait pris un engagement
en son nom et donc il doit à tout prix
reprendre des mains et les mettre en
mise à fig
tous les quatre tous les quatre et moi
je pousserai le bouchon à dire tous les
5 parce que on est venu il ya le
policier de la bac puis il est venu pour
camoufler
et puis pour agrandir le mention sur
lequel ils savaient plus comment faire
il sait pas comment faire
il a débarqué on sait pas comment enfin
sur un appel sur un appel comme on donne
sa concubine qui a crié au secours venez
vite on est dans le pétrin c'est plus
que ça du cdu est un truc comme ça et du
coup aujourd'hui ce qu'il ce qu'ils ont
oublié ce qu'il y avait des films y
avait des caméras il y avait des témoins
et aujourd'hui on peut pas revenir là
dessus
là c'est pas c'est pas une affaire où il
n'y a pas de preuves ya pas de témoins
n'y a rien il ya des témoins il ya des
vidéos
il ya des enregistrements tout démontre
que c'est un meurtre
voilà ça je le dis au nom de la famille
au nom de ses cinq enfants qui pleurent
toujours au nom de sa femme au nom de sa
mère sa soeur
aujourd'hui on est une famille qui a
anéanti assure un tissu de mensonges
et moi je vous dis on se battra jusqu'au
bout parce qu'il n'est pas question
qu'on laisse à quand on voit toutes les
preuves qui sait qu'ils sont accablantes
jusqu'à jusqu'à l'allemand le préfet
qu'avec kaka qui a été dans le tissu de
mensonges qui a couvert tout ça et
aujourd'hui on se pose la question
est-ce qu'il va rester pas restée moi je
vous le dit c'est des menteurs tous à la
plus grande à la plus grande hauteur du
gouvernement c'est un tissu de mensonges
on en a la preuve aujourd'hui ces
témoignages ont été approuvés par la
hiérarchie tse policiers on imagine non
seulement un sentiment d'injustice pour
vous mais aussi de la colère est ce que
vous pensez que la mort de votre fils va
faire évoluer les choses en france sur
les violences policières
on espère déjà que le pacage ventrale va
va être interdite on espère que la clé
d'étranglement va être interdite pour
des contrôles banal il ya aucune raison
qu'on en prêt on en place et on peut
convoquer les gens et pilar et leur
mettre des amendes
et puis on peut leur mettre des peines
de sursis en fonction de la laddh et le
des circonstances mais on n'est pas
obligé de tuer les gens pour un contrôle
pour une plaque salle où n'importe quoi
et puis parce que et puisque parce que
cédric a été et renier qui les a taquiné
avec de l'ironie et un autre qui
recueille la sortie des grossièretés il
est assez vrai ap les clowns ont dit pas
un politique c'est un clown on dit pas
on n'est pas irrespectueux mais dans
l'ironie est ce que vous croyez que ça
mérite la mort moi je demande aux
journalistes le demandent à la france
entière
est ce que vous croyez que ça mérite la
mort ont tué un père de cinq enfants qui
est un travailleur qui se lève le matin
et qui va au boulot
est ce que vous croyez que ça mérite ça
et on sent beaucoup d'émotion à travers
avec jean manuel effectivement
effectivement ça ça ne mérite pas la
mort c'est ce que vous nous dites en
direct sur la terre france ce soir
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
attendez désormais qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait pour ça change en tout cas pour
ça évolue en tout cas pour qu'il y ait
une justice juste à mort vis-à-vis de
ces violences policières
je me souviens que je veux que la presse
je veux que la presse continue à étaler
notre notre notre comment notre misère
qu'on lui a apportés qu'elles continuent
à groupe faire comprendre à croire comme
a fait libération comme un fait
médiapart qui servait 6 pour pour avoir
les preuves et quand on a les preuves
aujourd'hui les étals et comme ils l'ont
fait on a eu deux super équipe qui nous
ont grecs ont tous noté tous marqués
qu'ont fait les détails curité qui ont
été précis par rapport au rapport de
l'igpn est aujourd'hui c'est un peu
grâce à eux qu'on eut excusez moi le le
courage d'aller au charbon et de tout
est allé parce que maintenant
aujourd'hui il ya plus d'invoquer en
face y'a plus rien tout au long des
abats qu'est ce qui s'est passé là c'est
accablant c'est accablant
parce qu'il ya tellement de preuves il
l'appelle à tes bras carre à carre unis
qui a ramené beaucoup de monde et
aujourd'hui vous trouvez que vous
trouvez qu'on va encore pouvoir mentir
là c'est qui c'est qui est le premier
mini c'est
comment le ministre de la justice et qui
va arriver à faire quelque chose qui va
pouvoir doit entériner cette affaire on
pourra pas jamais d'entériner parce que
moi je vous le dis je me battrai jusqu'à
la dernière minute jusqu'au dernier
souffle pour que la vérité a éclaté
parce que ces gens-là ils seraient
condamnés ils ont toujours pas été mise
à pied vous trouvez ça normal
loties la sortie des insultes racistes
il a été mise à pied dans les 24 heures
qui suivaient et aujourd'hui on a tué un
homme qui travaillait qui est partie au
boulot on l'a tué sont toujours pas
mises à pied vous trouvez ça normal
est ce qu'on trouve ça normal
qu'aujourd'hui merci merci et question
merci beaucoup christophe il ya d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le père est de cédric ou via
homme de 42 ans et qui était mort lors
de 8 à son arrestation en janvier
dernier